une maladie du coeur sur deux qui n'a
pas été diagnostiquée il ya donc les
gens sont dans la nature une
probablement 30 à 50 % des cancers qui
n'ont pas été diagnostiqués en grande
bretagne en mars avril dont qui sont
dans la nature et on l'a probablement ce
cas là et donc c'est vrai que ça c'est
du tri parce que ce que nous avons pas
traités il ya un an que nous avons
essayé de récupérer très tardivement
vous imaginez qu'un cancer qu'on laisse
évalué évolué pendant huit ou neuf mois
là même la plus longue aux pronostics
des métastases sont apparus qu'on aurait
pu traiter et c'est de dire que les
déprogrammations aujourd'hui sont les
morts de demain mais c'est une certitude
on a dans nos déprogrammation
d'aujourd'hui puisque les de
programmation dont je vous parlais d'une
minute cet essai de lugano mais on
refait la même chose puisqu'on n'a pas
d'autre moyen puisqu'on n'a pas augmenté
nos capacités réelles
donc oui c'est vrai on a des patients
pour lesquelles le diagnostic ne sera
fait qui aurait dû être fait il ya dix
jours et il sera fait probablement en
mars avril mai juin juillet août
septembre
donc c'est ça qui est tragique et on va
demander nous les médecins de choisir
lequel qui aura sa fibroscopie de
l'estomac qui permettra de mettre en de
mettre en évidence le cancer de
l'estomac est ce monsieur x ou madame y
ce sera à nous de choisir et ça c'est
évidemment intolérable quand on est
médecin et moi je crois depuis le début
on ne fait pas suffisamment confiance
aux gens et cette question des autotests
est est un peu à l'image du reste
maintenant on a un tout petit sujet sur
les autotests qui est un vrai scandale
là pour le coup c'est comme ça a été
interdite par le gouvernement et un
arrêté du 12 juillet qui dit les
autotests sont interdits yako france a
interdit ça va être autorisée le seul
problème c'est comme les anglais et les
allemands tout acheter vous allez voir
on va pas arriver en acheter ça va
refaire avec les autotests le coût des
masques de ya un nom et c'est ça qui est
dingue est autorisée on va pouvoir les
avoir rapporté vous ne pourrez pas en
acheter parce que y en aura pas vous
savez c'est absolument fou autour il ya
un an
rétrospectivement on pourrait avec un
peu de charité chrétienne se dire au
fond c'était difficile ils ont eu du mal
etc
mais un an plus tard on a appris de ses
erreurs et on est toujours aussi peu
près et ça pour moi c'est une
c'est une question absolument impossible
à résoudre je ne sais pas pourquoi on
est toujours
nous sommes toujours à préparer pas
pourquoi on les a interdits moi je
souvent jetés face à des membres du
gouvernement
olive et veyran par tweets interposés
attal sur un plateau lancker partout
interposés et les réponses c'était à oui
mais ce sont des tests qui ne sont pas
suffisamment sûres donc ils sont sûrs en
allemagne ils sont sûrs en grande
bretagne mais ils ne sont pas sûrs pour
nous c'est la france